hello everyone and welcome to
chess.com's World bullet Chess
Championship we have a very nice game
between Eric Hansen and Magnus Carlsen
you can see that the ratings are very
much different from the from the usual
classical or Rapid or or Blitz ratings
these are bullet ratings and as you can
play uh many many many more games than
you can play in shorter time formats of
course the ratings will be higher and um
uh okay they've played a lot of games I
chose the one that I I thought was the
most interesting to show as we have not
one exchange sacrifice but two exchange
sacrifices in well everyone's favorite
the king's Indian defense so let's check
it out uh neither of these two fine
gentlemen need any introduction Eric has
the white pieces and he opens with Pawn
to D4 uh Knight to F6 by Magnus C for G6
uh going for the king's Indian defense
Knight to C3 and Bishop to G7 with Pawn
to E4 uh so all fairly standard stuff
and pawn to F3 now we have Pawn to D6
and the bishop to E3 we have Ponte 5 and
now Knight G to E2 e captures on D4
Knight captures on D4 and now just Pawn
to C6 we have Queen to D2 at some point
you might even consider Castle in Queen
side maybe trade trading off the dark
Square Bishops Rook to E8 and now Bishop
to E2 castling uh Queen side is a bit
more more popular but Bishop to E2 and
here they're actually following a very
very popular game that was played uh in
none other than a World Chess
Championship match but we're gonna get
to that we have Pawn to D5 uh Eric's
King is now still in the center of the
board so of course Magnus wants to open
up the position he captures on d5c
captures and now Pawn to C5 uh
interestingly uh the game that I
mentioned was Anatoly carpool versus
Gary because probably was played in game
11 of their uh Leon New York World Chess
Championship in 1990 where karpov
decided the castle King side also you
can Castle Queen side here you could
also play Rook to D1 here there are many
possible ideas here but there it goes
for a pawn to C5 it's sort of a a newer
very very tricky approach but if you if
you know how to play against it it
shouldn't yield anything good for white
but it's bullet so of course you can
play anything so Knight to C6 and now we
have castles uh okay instead of Knight
to C6 you could have gone for the C5
Pawn tonight the B3 defends the pawn and
the game continues and now while you
could continue with something passive
like Bishop to f8 try and win the pawn
go Queen to A5 Magna just goes Rook
captures on E3 and this is the first
exchange sacrifice I know some of you
will be like okay but the exchange
sacrifice is not a real sacrifice but
it's still a sacrifice how how do I I
don't know how to how to call it
otherwise and okay Queen captures on E3
and now Queen to f8 getting ready to
pick up that C5 pawn and now the
question is uh can you just play Knight
to B3 and say you've sacrificed this for
nothing well if you play Knight to B3
there is a very tricky move here uh and
it actually wins the game for black so
just for fun feel free to pause the
video and try to find this winning idea
in this position that never occurred
while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding this uh
incredible uh well it's sort of a
combination of everything and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Pawn to D4 this win's a piece and
here you just resign uh as uh if you
capture the pawn Knight captures on D4
yes you are defending it but there's
Knights the G4 and now the queen is
attacked and also there's a double
attack on the Knight on D4 and if you
capture them Bishop captures and D4
picks up the queen and if you don't
capture then you have to move the queen
what can you play a queen to F4 but then
again you capture this with check and
once the king moves then you can play
Knight to F2 check and now you have the
capture if you don't if you just play
King G1 then Knight to D3 opens up a
discovery and you lose the queen on F4
so here you would have the capture and
not only do you win your peace back but
you also win the exchange back but you
also will be an extra piece at the end
of this so that's why after Queen to f8
Eric cannot just go Knight to B3 he
plays Knight captures on C6 B captures
on C6 and now King to H1 and yes this is
bullet but it's one plus one uh so when
you're playing online and you do get
incremented this is quite a lot of time
especially for these uh incredible
bullet experts uh like Eric and Magnus
so uh here they're still in the game
that uh kasparian carpool and Sparrow
will were playing in their World Chess
Championship Match uh the game continued
with Rook to B8 and it's uh definitely a
move that makes sense going after the B2
Pawn but Magnus uh uh plays a different
move he doesn't go for the move that
kasparo played he played a knight to D7
and now it's different in the actual
game a carpool versus kaspar uh B3 was
played but here you can do that because
now the bishop has opened up and this
would be very dangerous and of course it
is only now as of move 16 that we have a
completely new game which is somewhat
the weird to you guys sometimes you will
be like but how can they play Such
incredible chess with only a minute on
the clock and the second increment well
that's just how good they are most of
the games they played are like 90 80
percent accuracy so 1984 defending the
opponent C5 also defending the pawn on
B2 and now Rook to B8 putting pressure
on the pawn and now Rook a to B1 of
course you cannot play B3 uh Rook to B4
Magnus brings The Rook into the game and
now Pawn to B3 with Ponte H5 and Bishop
to D3 and here Magnus gives up the
second exchange he plays a rook captures
on A4 uh to grab the C5 pawn and then to
just try and win the game uh pushing
those Central pawns because now after B
captures an A4 and you eliminated the
pawn on C5 you get two connected pass
Pawns in the center of the board
is this uh enough for for giving up not
one exchange but two well let's see how
the game continues to Rook the B8
uh this is a very nice move the bishop
now cannot move both the queen and the
King are on the back rank Knight the D7
attacks The Rook Rook A8 and now Pawn to
C5 Magnus with full control over the
center the bishop is looking very nice
here but it's very dangerous Bishop to
B5 the thread is Bishop captures the
Knight on D7 as the bishop cannot move
uh so here we have Knight the uh Knights
the B6 attacks The Rook defends the
bishop and The Rook captures an A7 with
Bishop to E6 by Magnus and now Rook the
B7 so Magnus is in a very very difficult
position here but he of course has the
two connected pass pawns and he starts
pushing them Pawn to D4 Queen to G5 and
now Knight to D5 and here there are many
moves that are winning for Eric like
Pawn to A5 like Bishop to D7 Bishop to
C4 also but he played Bishop to C6 which
is also kind of winning it just allows
Magnus a free Tempo and that's a very
dangerous uh thing to give a player like
Magnus Queen to D6 and now you can just
continue pushing your pass Pawn because
the bishop and C6 is hanging so he
captures on D5 but now Bishop captures
attacks The Rook so again you cannot
start advancing your pass pawn and you
should play something like Queen to E7
and the game continues probably of
course you don't trade then comes Rook
to B5 and so on the game continues but
here Eric actually played Pawn to A5 he
gave up the rook and B7 uh maybe he
blundered it it's hard to say because uh
it's a bullet uh but he might have had
some idea Bishop captures on B7 was
played now comes Rook to B1 uh and queen
to E6 offering the bishop here for a
very nice Checkmate on E1 so of course
Eric plays Pawn to H4 and now just
Bishop to A6 getting the bishop out of
harms away we have Queen captures on C5
and now Pawn to D3 Magnus continues
pushing his pass pawn queen to B6 now
offering a queen trade and now while you
could go for something like Queen
captures and A2 Magnus plays Pawn to D2
and here the trick is it's actually a
pawn blunder a pure Pawn blunder because
you can take it with Queen to d8 check
followed by Queen captures on D2 uh and
yeah you you can also see just uh even
even though they are such extremely
strong players they will blunder at this
time control even though I believe
Magnus at this point was over 30 seconds
on the clock he wasn't even he hasn't
even used up half of his time but yeah
Eric missed Queen today to check to pick
up the Free Pawn he played uh Rook to D1
just blocking the pawn and now Magnus
played Queen to E1 with check and he was
in this position on the Move 35 that
Eric Hansen resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
the problem is of course if you just
move the king then you lose the rook and
if you take the queen then another queen
comes into the game with check and after
King to H2 of course you just get the
checkmated bishop to E5 check and that's
it there's no no zero counter play here
King H3 and queen to H1 will be
Checkmate so yeah very very nicely done
by both of them uh both all of the games
like I said were played at an incredible
accuracy Magnus won a lot more than Eric
so magnus's games were a bit more
accurate but here are the final results
so Magnus uh won the the match with 16
and a half uh to one and a half very
nicely and also in the other match of
the uh quarterfinals Sergio netgee still
lost with six points to 11 to at one
Mill Lane so we'll see what happens uh
later on in the tournament so this is
only one of the games uh that I thought
was very nice as uh we will enjoy a nice
Kings Indian defense we all enjoy it to
see an exchange sacrifice in the king's
Indian and now we've seen what happens
which do exchange sacrifices it's a
shame Eric could give up that Rook on C6
uh you know probably would have been a
very different game but still due to
exchange sacrifices you know putting
such pressure having the the two
connected past pawns the bishop
controlling this diagonal you can see
that it's not easy and if you are
playing online if you are playing it
lower time controls you can always
consider uh tactics like these uh and
you know it will put your opponents
under a lot of pressure uh so yeah
that's the game really hope you guys
enjoyed it if you have any of your own
favorites do use hashtag suggestion and
I will go over them I would like to
thank David Kimura Rod Hill Phil Malthus
Johan Bridger and Richard Phillips for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous this video
Sarah thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World uh thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day